nous avons conduit dans une rue un soir la
rue je ne savais pas que nous devrions penser
à un équipage parfois attendre Nolan prends
les vacances es-tu heureux
je veux dire que tu es ici depuis 25 ans
maintenant il avait 26 ans devait avoir pensé à
faire un changement  de temps en temps je
pense que tu n'es pas comme je pensais je
suppose que
tout d'un coup j'ai 60 ans eh bien tu veux
me donner le droit tu m'as demandé si tu
voulais me conduire bien sûr je ne connais même pas
ton nom Leo  Je sais que je suis vraiment
débordé au travail ici et la seule façon de
m'en sortir comme si je restais tard, nous avons
des lits séparés, des chambres séparées en direct
,
j'ai besoin de te parler leo, je ne le
connais pas, sors de mon  maison j'essaie juste
de t'aider du tout
j'ai essayé de t'appeler à la banque hé
princesse mais ce n'est pas le mien bonjour
oh mon dieu sachant ce qui s'est passé je ne peux pas
te tromper et je sais que tu peux
je t'aime joie je n'ai jamais été  un mensonge
il est juste temps pour nous d'être dans le monde réel
peut-être qu'il n'est jamais trop tard pour enfin
commencer à vivre la vie que vous voulez vraiment